welcome to the second part of the
presentation on basic trigonometry in
the last ten minutes I had trouble
getting a lot of examples so I want to
do a couple more with you guys okay so
let's uh let me start over just because
it's got messy and we're going to do
what we did the last time around so let
me just draw another right triangle and
make sure it's not going to be too big
okay so here's my right triangle and let
me just throw out some random sides let
me say that this is six this is let's
make this side five and then if this is
a right triangle Pythagorean theorem
tells us that this would be the square
root of what 36 plus 25 is equal to the
square root of 61 I think that's right
I've gotten feedback on some of my other
videos that I tend to get this type of
addition wrong
I'm malfunkshun sometimes but anyway so
this side is the square root of 61
that's the hypotenuse so let's get
started with some problems if I were to
give you if I were to ask you well let's
see let's call this angle let's call
this angle theta and I want to know what
is what is the tangent of theta and
we'll short that is tangent of tan of
theta what is the tangent of this angle
right here well you probably already
forgot what the definition of tangent is
so I will repeat it in fact I will write
up in this corner so Chi Toa
so and I think now your brain might be
refreshing to remember that Toa is the
mnemonic for tangent and it says the
tangent is equal to the opposite over
the adjacent so the tangent of theta is
equal to the opposite side well that's
this side that's the side this length
five over the adjacent side that's this
side the side of length 6 that's pretty
easy huh the tangent of theta is 5 over
6
and we'll just do a couple more I will
just go through all of the trig
functions or at least the basic trig
functions what is the sine of theta well
let's go back to our mnemonic sohcahtoa
this is one of the few things in
mathematics that you should probably
memorize it's kind of a funny word
anyway and so define sine and tells us
that sine is opposite over hypotenuse
opposite over hypotenuse well the
opposite side once again is five and
what's the hypotenuse well the
hypotenuse we just figured out was the
square root of 61 the square root of 61
and a lot of people don't like
irrational denominator so we can
rationalize the denominator and when we
do that by multiplying the numerator and
the denominator by this square root of
61 so if we if we say that this is equal
to 5 over the square root of 61 times
the square root of 61 over the square
root of 61 right we're just multiplying
it by 1 because this is the same thing
top and bottom this equals 5 square
roots of 61 over what's the square root
of 61 times the square root of 61
oh yeah it's it's 61 so the sine of
theta is 5 square roots of 61 over 61
and then finally let me make some space
here let me erase some stuff let me let
me erase this one right here and you're
probably still wondering what okay I
kind of get this whole sine tangent
cosine thing what is it useful for and
all I can tell you right now is get to
know how to use these sohcahtoa and in
the next presentation in other words
we're going to show you that
trigonometry is actually probably one of
the most obviously useful things in math
you can figure out all sorts of things
how far planets are how tall buildings
are I mean there's tons of things you
could figure out what trigonometry and
then later we'll we'll study sine waves
and cosine waves and all of that you'll
learn that it actually describes some
almost almost everything but anyway
going back to the problem we all we're
left now is cosine
oh the cupcake that is cosine of theta
equals we'll go back to our mnemonic
sohcahtoa well cosine is adjacent over
hypotenuse so once again what's the
adjacent side well this is the angle
we're finding the cosine of so the
adjacent side is right here
it's a length six so it equals the
adjacent side which is six right and we
figured out what the hypotenuse was
that's this side it's length square root
of 61 and if we rationalize this
denominator we get six square roots of
61 over 61 it's kind of messy numbers
but I think now you get the hang of
figuring out if you know the sides of a
triangle figuring out what the sine the
cosine or the tangent of any given angle
in that right triangle is and obviously
you can't figure it out for the for the
for this angle because for this angle
the opposite in the a and the hypotenuse
are actually the same number so actually
not never mind you actually can't figure
it out
but it actually gives something an
interesting number so with that said I
will finish this presentation and then
in the next presentation I will show you
how if we know what the sine or the
cosine or the tangent of an angle is and
we know one of the sides how we can
figure out the other sides see in the
next presentation by